you know you aren't friends once in a
while because you played Phoebe's
boyfriend and husband right yeah you
guys got married and were you viewing
that at that point in your career like
hey it's kind of cool to just drop in on
a show yeah I mean I was only ever
supposed to do I think two episodes and
they liked you on it till they wrote you
in more it was in then it was it really
nearing the end of the show is there I
think it went ten seasons and I came in
on the ninth season you said something
where you thought it was a joke do you
remember this story that you went to
Jennifer Aniston I guess it was the last
show oh yeah yeah you could say to her
well it wanted to do something funny it
was just weird because with the last
episode of Friends that was a massive
story
huge huge it and you're there and
they're all crying and catching
emotional experiences they've been there
for ten years a grown up with each other
on this show and made their name would
this show everything and now what was
ending and I'm still in that oh my god I
can't believe there's that Jew a sign
that's over the you know hanging over
the television and so Jennifer and Marta
Kauffman the writer they were you know
they would they were hugging and crying
and I would just go over and join the
that be embrace and say guys what a ride
huh
anyway that's funny
what a ride but they didn't like that
you said you were fine with bomb you're
like a bomb what a ride yeah I bombed I
would that is a common thing where you
know the joke gene kicks in and it's
like dude read the room you said the
first day on the set there that you
thought you were gonna get play because
you took a set you're riding around the
set on a Segway and you ran over
Jennifer Aniston's bush she had a segue
I think it was the first episode maybe
even if it was the first or second
episode and she had a segue because I
think it was a brand new thing you know
what she was if around the under said
yeah and her foot had been injured like
she had I don't know I think she had had
a broken foot not that she needed a
segue to get around but she was kind of
using this thing and and so matt LeBlanc
wanted to try it and I and I said oh can
I try I'd never say let's have some fun
yeah yeah and she was holding it as I
was standing on it and saying okay just
be careful because you know the
finding your center of gravity as a
challenge and I was okay and and then
she let go and I started to lean back or
turn and I turned the thing instead of
going straight and it just ran over from
a bad her bad foot what was the
aftermath that did she start like crying
ah and then and then and then uh and I
could tell I'm gonna shoot like
immediate shock there were a group of
people including writers of producers
all running over they looked but it
completely freaked out she said I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay and then she's down
she is she said it is she is she like
wincing and and like she was in pain oh
yeah yeah no no she was she she was
playing it up a little just to make you
feel bad I mean I think it was that
default mechanism in her she's like no
no don't worry it's fine I'm okay I'm
okay I just I just need to sit down for
a spot was it like oh I'm okay I'm okay
hand up just give me a sec just give me
so everyone wants to hated you
oh yeah I know I felt like I just did
complete had a ride the Segway yeah yeah
yeah had a ride why matt LeBlanc is
obviously familiar around vehicles he
hosted the driving show I shouldn't be
honest when he runs over her foot he's a
regular on the show he's got equals and
I can't rid of Joey no they're not but
my turn Anakin yeah I could get you no
one's gonna miss my game remember they
might have